le système de santé en norvège ça
fonctionne très bien
julien bourg elle vit en norvège depuis
13 ans
[Musique]
les il habite dans cette jolie banlieue
d'oslo depuis peu il a donc dû changer
de médecin de famille sur internet c'est
tout centraliser puis le service et les
très bons
on va sur ce qui s'appelle santé norvège
donc le site du gouvernement norvégien
québécois d'origine il a aussi vécu
ailleurs dans le monde on clique sur
changer le médecin puis ça nous donne
une liste on fait de tout les médecins
dans notre région où on peut choisir il
se dit impressionné par la souplesse du
système norvégienne donc lui à cette
place sur 1250 qui sont disponibles
[Musique]
la grande transparence de ce système
d'accès est en général bien accepté par
les médecins norvégienne
tout le monde peut voir quels médecins
qui existent combien de la saison et
peut même être même sur la liste à
tanger un médecin qui n'a pas de place
ça veut dire que l'accès pas seulement
médecins mais aussi au registre très bon
en effet sur le système actuel a été
mise en place en 2001 la norvège vivait
alors une crise similaire à celle du
québec les médecins pouvaient accepter
les patients de leur choix
il y avait aucune liste de public près
de 10% de la population n'avait pas de
médecin attitré la plupart étant des
personnes plus malade est plus
vulnérable corps et le renard le
gouvernement de l'époque a donc choisi
de renverser les rôles aujourd'hui c'est
le patient qui choisit tous les
habitants norvège ont droit à un médecin
ils peuvent aussi changer et on a en loi
qui dit que si vous téléphonez chez
votre généraliste
ils doivent prendre le téléphone en
moins de deux minutes et doivent même
donné un haut niveau au moins de cinq
jours petit détail les patients doivent
payer des frais modérateurs de base à
toutes les visites pour une visite chez
un médecin ce à peu près 20 euros des
fois un peu plus des frappes de loin il
ya un limite d'à peu près 200 euros par
an ce serait peut-être un équivalent de
700 $ au québec ou au canada elle tout
coûte de 3 à 5 fois plus cher en norvège
donc ça fonctionne bien les gens
normalement vois ça comme quelque chose
de positif de payer un petit petite
partie du coût de tuer un médecin ça
aussi c'est un site web autre
particularité norvégienne les patients
peuvent évaluer la performance de leur
médecin sur un portail public un peu
comme un convoi au restaurant quand on
va sur google maps ou remet les étoiles
pour différents services et linda t il
est noté
julien bourg elle était venue en norvège
pour obtenir un doctorat en ingénierie
au fil du temps il a plutôt choisi
d'étudier à fond la culture norvégienne
et il est devenu conférencier très prisé
sur le sujet
comme un programme maintenant je vis ça
je fais des conférences partout en
scandinavie et maintenant ou si à
travers le monde sur les différences
culturelles il observe que les médecins
n'ont pas de statut social particulier
ici leurs salaires sont très bons
l'équivalent de deux fois et demie le
revenu moyen au pays mais c'est beaucoup
moins qu'au québec par exemple où les
médecins ont un revenu cinq fois
supérieur au salaire moyenne dans l'ue
pour vous faut lui même aime le concept
d'élite et existe très peu en norvège
mais pipeau de travail pis
ce médecin généraliste sous ministre de
la santé explique que les salles
d'urgence étaient souvent bondés avant
la réforme et c'est beaucoup moins le
cas aujourd'hui
mais la norvège comme d'autres pays fait
face à de nouveaux défis en médecine
générale
population vieillissante augmentation de
la charge de travail pénurie de médecins
on lit tout le temps des histoires des
maires qui sont généralistes y
travaillent jusqu'à 4 5 heures ils vont
aller au au jardin enfants pour chercher
leurs enfants et font à manger il est
cauchy continue travail de 10 heures
jusqu'à minuit chaque jour à des
orques ainsi le taux de satisfaction
générale envers le système de santé
demeure très élevé en norvège comme le
confirme la conjointe de juliet bourrel
norvégienne d'origine et ex infirmière
en milieu hospitalier
le modèle norvégien est il exportable au
canada peut-être mais il faudrait aussi
importer une partie de la mentalité
locale ce qui est typiquement en norvège
c'est qu'on veut avoir une contribution
au pays pour aider la société plus que
pourra avoir un
niveau social plus élevé l'exemple de la
norvège démontrent que les patients qui
sont suivis sur une longue période par
le même médecin ont moins besoin d'être
hospitalisés et leur qualité de vie s'en
trouve nettement améliorée
pour